Quand on nous dit qu'un empereur des temps modernes
porte de nouveaux vêtements,
les caricatures révèlent que l'empereur est peut-être encore nu.
(Parle espagnol)
A un moment de ma carrière,
j'ai dessiné des cochons
et les ai comparés aux politiciens et à la garde nationale
qui étaient responsables de l'interruption de manifestations étudiantes pacifiques.
Un jour, quand je suis revenue au bureau,
j'avais une lettre sur mon bureau.
(Parle espagnol)
Cette lettre venait de la fédération porcine vénézuélienne.
(Rires)
(Parle espagnol)
La lettre disait :
« Merci de ne pas comparer un animal aussi merveilleux que le cochon
à des politiciens.
Les cochons sont gentils et nobles,
faisant de super mascottes ou animaux de compagnie
et ils contribuent à nous nourrir sous la forme du porc. »
(Parle espagnol)
Je pense qu'ils avaient raison et je n'ai plus dessiné de cochons
mais j'ai continué à dessiner des politiciens.
(Rires)
(Parle espagnol)
Une caricature voyage sur une autoroute de l'information
qui semble avoir de multiples voies
mais, en réalité, toutes ces voies
mènent à une réponse binaire : de la positivité ou de la fureur.
« J'aime » et « Je n'aime pas ».
Ce sont les seules réponses
régissant la pensée démocratique sur internet.
(Parle espagnol)
Nous avons perdu l'espace pour un débat nuancé,
nous n'avons pas le temps,
nous répondons simplement avec approbation ou dédain
et nous laissons les algorithmes prendre la main.
(Parle espagnol)
Mais une caricature naît d'une réflexion profonde et nuancée.
Créer une bonne caricature implique des échecs répétés,
brouillon après brouillon.
Un caricaturiste doit se débarrasser de ses tabous
pour susciter une conversation, plutôt qu'une confrontation,
à travers son travail.
(Parle espagnol)
Au cours de l'année 2013, le président Chavez est décédé
et j'ai dû réfléchir à quoi dessiner pour la caricature du jour
chez « La Universal ».
Personnellement, j'étais contente qu'il soit décédé
car je pensais que la fin de son pouvoir
rapprocherait potentiellement notre pays de la liberté et de jours meilleurs.
(Parle espagnol)
Mais de nombreuses autres personnes pleuraient le décès de Chavez,
les sentiments étaient donc divisés au Venezuela.
Certains faisaient la fête
et d'autres pleuraient la perte de leur leader.
(Parle espagnol)
Je me sentais coincée,
j'ignorais quoi dessiner lors de ce moment historique.
Je savais ne pas pouvoir laisser mon bonheur infiltrer mon travail,
que je devais m'élever au-dessus de cela et respecter la peine des gens.
Que pouvais-je dessiner ?
(Parle espagnol)
J'ai passé de nombreuses heures à faire des ébauches et à les jeter.
Mon éditeur m'a appelée et a dit
que tout était en retard pour le journal du jour
et m'a demandée quand j'aurais fini.
C'est au milieu de la nuit que l'idée m'est venue.
Nous avons publié une caricature qui représentait un moment historique.
(Parle espagnol)
Une pièce d'échecs rouge, un roi déchu.
Une bonne caricature a beaucoup de pouvoir.
Elle peut susciter des actions et des réactions.
C'est pourquoi un caricaturiste doit exercer son pouvoir de façon responsable,
montrer la vérité
et dessiner sans craindre les conséquences.
(Parle espagnol)
Avoir une opinion a un coût
et, dans certains pays, ce coût est élevé.
(Parle espagnol)
Au Venezuela,
beaucoup de jeunes ont été tués pour des manifestations pacifiques.
Il y a des hommes et des femmes derrière les barreaux
en tant que prisonniers politiques.
Au fil des années,
j'ai dessiné les visages de femmes emprisonnées
car je ne veux pas qu'elles soient oubliées par la communauté.
(Parle espagnol)
Cette année, durant un événement appelé « El Floro Penal »,
qui est un forum pénal
où des avocats travaillent bénévolement
pour les prisonniers politiques vénézuéliens,
une jeune femme est venue me voir et m'a dit :
« J'ai été emprisonnée,
puis vous avez dessiné mon visage et mon histoire.
C'est du fait de ce dessin que les gens ont su qui j'étais.
Votre caricature m'a aidée à survivre à mes jours en prison.
Merci. »
(Parle espagnol)
C'est un moment qui a beaucoup compté pour moi
car j'avais trouvé une façon de collaborer
avec les souvenirs de mon pays et de son peuple.
(Parle espagnol)
L'année dernière, j'ai commencé à faire des dessins sur l'immigration.
J'ai dessiné mon monde, mes peurs,
ma valise, mes racines
et tout ce que j'avais dû laisser derrière moi au Venezuela.
J'ai aussi dessiné la joie face à cette nouvelle opportunité
en tant qu'immigrante aux États-Unis.
(Parle espagnol)
De là, j'ai travaillé sur une série de dessins
représentant l'expérience et la psychologie de l'immigration.
(Parle espagnol)
Être un immigrant, c'est comme déménager sur une autre planète.
Au début, vous ne comprenez rien de votre nouveau monde.
Il y a de nouveaux codes, une nouvelle langue
et des outils inconnus que vous devez apprendre à utiliser
afin de vous adapter à votre nouvelle vie.
(Parle espagnol)
Être un immigrant, c'est ce qu'il y a de plus proche à être un astronaute
ayant atterri sur la Lune.
(Parle espagnol)
Avec le temps, cette série de dessins est devenue une exposition itinérante
appelée « Moi, Immigrant.e ».
Et l'exposition est allée dans de multiples villes,
y compris Miami, Houston, Madrid, Barcelone,
et nous espérons qu'elle ira dans plus d'endroits.
(Parle espagnol)
L'exposition est devenue un lieu de rencontre pour la diaspora,
pour que les gens se réunissent
et reconnaissent leurs souffrances communes
liées à l'immigration.
(Parle espagnol)
Je veux que ces dessins communiquent
qu'un immigrant n'est pas un criminel.
Un immigrant est une personne dont la vie a été brisée.
Une personne qui a très probablement été séparée de sa famille
dans des conditions inhumaines.
Qui a été forcée de quitter son pays en quête d'une vie meilleure.
(Parle espagnol)
Un dessin peut être la synthèse d'un lieu,
d'un univers, d'un pays ou d'une société.
Il peut aussi représenter
les rouages internes de l'esprit de quelqu'un.
Pour moi, dessiner des caricatures est une forme de résistance.
(Parle espagnol)
Une caricature est comme une pierre de Rosette.
Si nous la lançons dans l'espace,
un extraterrestre sera capable de savoir avec certitude
que dans le passé,
nous avions un monde civilisé avec une pensée libre.
(Parle espagnol)
Ce mur sur lequel ma mère m'a offert la liberté d'écrire semble sans limites.
Et c'est pour cette raison que je dessine encore.
Merci beaucoup.
(Acclamations et applaudissements)